Hello, we are in Northeast Iowa and thinking of gardening, yay, yay, I'm all for gardening.
So do you use any organic fertilizer on yours?
We have it in the past but wondering what you do as this is your passion also with harvesting.
Do you can or freeze or what kind of storage do you use?
So come this summer.
I will share more if you want to see more pictures of our garden because my wife and I are
very avid gardeners and our garden is very pretty, I think and it's so much fun.
So I just believe God put us put man in the garden for the beginning for a very specific
reason and I just love gardening.
So do we use any organic fertilizer?
Well, my wife bought I bought this stuff for our fruit trees last year.
I actually didn't put it on and I forgot to get it on.
I'm going to put it on this year.
This is the doctor earth's organic fertilizer.
My wife got some other, I think it's the same brand for the, it's four vegetables and for flowers,
she's huge into flowers to see her flower garden.
But there's other brands, the brands of organic fertilizer, I don't think I do worry so much
about what you're putting on your flowers, but on your vegetables, we either don't use
really much for a produced fertilizer, we do a lot of composting, we add a lot of compost
to our soil, so that's really how we mainly fertilize.
We used to have rabbits, we'd use that fertilizer to our soil.
We had horses, we'd put horse manure on our soil, we'd always be tilling an organic fertilizer
on our soil.
As far as harvesting, we do catting both hot water bath and pressure catting, we do freeze
our vegetables.
You know, there's argument you lose nutrients, hot water bath aid or pressure catting your
vegetables, you lose nutrients in the water, yes, that's true, you will lose nutrients
that way.
You still will lose nutrients if you're freezing your vegetables, we're actually really
praying about getting a freeze dry or they're very expensive, but we literally have so many
raspberries and strawberries and blackberries, we just started growing blackberries and different
vegetables, and our kids and grad kids love eating the freeze dried stuff that's produced
out there, so we like to get that to store it with that too.